[Musique]
quelle est la différence entre un mec
pour y est un mec bien qui fait des
trucs pourris
où est la frontière entre un mensonge
innocent et le mal absolu
pas de quartier je veux que tu leur
arrachent les vieux je t'ai parlé lui
john tu joues est un vrai génie
j'aimerais beaucoup connaître ta
stratégie messieurs et si on faisait de
l'argent neuf
le bbc
la seule différence entre les
investissements à haut risque et une
pyramide de ponzi
c'est le résultat cette affaire va
rapporter un quart de milliard de
dollars aujourd'hui ne seront plus
jamais les mêmes
on va le milliardaire
tu as déjà conduit
ce bolide vaut plus cher que mon appart
m
tu es un peu bordélique jo tu avais des
dépenses courantes avec les faons t'es
au courant
du coup je viens les bourses street tu
crois vraiment qu'on peut faire fortune
sans tricher il est où le pognon
l'argent n'existait pas vraiment remis
ron levin m'a mis sur la paille comment
je dois beaucoup d'argent à beaucoup de
monde je dois absolument les rembourser
si le bbc se casse la figure
toute notre comptabilité de l'année
écoulée va passer sous le microscope du
fisc de l'asse du fbi y aille
comment vous l'obligent aurier à nous
rendre notre fric j'ai compris ce jour
là que parfois la vérité et le mensonge
idéal au 8 mai du scotch sur la bouche
pour pas l'entendre crier
viléo en évident quel club il ya des
poches
il n'y a plus qu'une seule chose à faire
sauver les meubles et en finir
tu culpabilises pas du tout
papa est rentré à la maison
pas bon petit est partout mais ta gueule
tu vois pas je suis en train de jouer
les cafés à steffi détendue la fina
mauvais coton genre table d'hôte arrête
avec tes expressions du moyen-âge les
ponts dix de blessés
bonjour donnes tu commences à me courir
sur le haricot vraiment un prêt d'un
truc tu retombes dans les psys quoi
l'autre obsédé avec ses dessins pervers
que voyez-vous sur ceux des chats des
sens et la effet ce sont des gens tout
nus qui tient alors annoncer mes photos
de vacances
[Musique]
et demi par tous à vos yeux
votre bouche cuisse
media group r
[Musique]
je dirige un type d'établissement tout
spécialement conçu pour accueillir de
jeunes personnes comme toi une courte
période d'acclimatation pour être
nécessaire mais tu verras que la paix et
la sérénité n'ont pas leur pareil pour
apaiser les esprits comme il est dit
dans la sainte bible
seul le contact avec la nature permet à
l'homme de redevenir pur
je crois que tu tentes aigre va très
bien
c'est quoi ces bêtes de cirque pourquoi
tu as toi parce que mes parents m'ont
morts
à des parents ils m'ont dit que c'était
pour le nouveau semestre le dr sherman
s'est fixé pour but d'atteindre la
clarté dans les deux prochaines semaines
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre et il
n'est pas question que je fréquente cet
établissement vous n'avez pas le choix
mademoiselle vous le groupe
[Musique]
on reprend la place après temps il faut
construire d'ici
[Musique]
les dr sherman vous enseigner une leçon
aujourd'hui j'espère que vous et métiers
octobre 1989 43 femmes à travers le
monde donnait naissance à un enfant
aucune de ces femmes n'étaient tombées
en 5 auparavant
[Musique]
combien puis-je vous en offrir j'ai
adopté
six de ces êtres prodigieux
doté de capacités
présente la toute première place de
l'homme mme breillat academy
l'un d'entre vous soit il prendre la
parole c'était un monstre c'est tout
contrat famille qui est dingue
salariales levant
[Musique]
c'est ma jupe que tu portes sous le
mérite de se voir agri du parti c'est
cool de voir que rien n'a changé
quand j'ai sauté que je me suis retrouvé
coincé dans le futur tu sais ce que j'ai
trouvé rien du tout c'est prévu pour cor
exactement dans huit jours
il ya une personne qui va m'empêcher de
sauver le monde
il faudrait que l'académie soit au grand
complet
un aux franges et non à nouveau en
finale
lève toi on y va tous à sauver le monde
on se trouve là
non
tu veux que je te raconte une histoire
flippante
il faut que tu gardes le contrôle ou et
alex maintenant
pourquoi tu ne dis pas ce qui s'est
passé avec angie tu es vraiment trop
bizarre aujourd'hui
sérieux c'est quelque chose qu'elle t'a
dit vas-y entre comme ça tu verras la
tête de con de mon père je dis rien
[Musique]
depuis la sitab soit pour quoi que ce
soit je vais compter à rebours à partir
de 10 et à un tu travailleras maman
tu devrais pas être là alex est encore
là oui elle doit rester dormir ici
si les clés de la bagnole de mon père
tu veux bien laisser hadji tranquille tu
arriveras jamais à croire ce qui est en
train de m'arriver du amis dans l'axé
soit son problème
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
wahaha
d
c'est le moment de se réveiller ni
il était en course rencontre dont les
assiettes tant appris qu'on dise oh je
bougeais pas toujours pourquoi tu as
pris tout ça alors
parce que c'est gratos le all inclusive
c'est de voir la maman cousin conseils
de vieil pro remis au buffet premiers
transats pour les boissons
on mélange mais moi de zombies coco ho
brin inquiet râle quand deux tiers d'eau
ok alors quatre bras olindo ville
il faut mettre le paquet sur les
animations je ne veux pas voir un mot
qui s'ennuient un mot qui s'éclate c'est
un bon mot qui va bien et un moment qui
va bien c'est un mot qui revenait du
matin on se serait pas déjà croisé
quelque part tous les temps dans nos
coeurs peut-être
non
[Musique]
je le dis comme ça en passant je suis
retraité et veut donc libre très bon
savoir traverser
j'ai perdu mon baluchon que c'est la
cata mon baluchon servait le chou un
ballon chaud en forme de ballon
cabano celle perdue le port trois
maillots et de tissus mammaires dans le
baluchon bruno damet la mort d'un
moineau willow maman tu me fais quoi là
jeff suppan acloque d'accord j'ai le
grand carnaval
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
ap houston
soliste et la teneur
[Musique]
ou plus
[Applaudissements]
la casse en france
non
un intervenant
[Musique]